[Applause]
the dog please take a seat sir we're
live on the air it's all good please
take a seat you could oh wait let me
help you uh
say my first thank you here we go thank
you
oh you don't want to do that
oh my goodness you didn't ask for
consent
[Laughter]
she's very protective of her dad okay
would you mind holding her in your other
arm because if you do that then we'll be
able to see
bubbles then she'll be further away no
no because the microphone
no no no no because the microphone
obscures bubbles the dog yeah yeah yeah
bubbles yeah so yeah bubbles
bubbles bites those nippers dogs can
sense evil
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no [ __ ]
i'll accept that i'll accept it i mean
that's the thing
that i've heard no i you know she she
was a rescue and uh okay and and you
know sophia was the one who wanted a dog
i've never had a pet i remember you did
not want because we went out to dinner
with you and susie right after we got
her and i was not i was like i traveled
you you were looking at a baby monitor
the entire time like or your or your or
no pardon me your your uh your home
monitor yeah we had like we have like a
baby monitor when we go out to dinner
and leave her there but now i have the
eu password she has a european union
password
yeah yeah no and then she has a little
id like a service dog id so uh so i can
take her anywhere legally you can't
throw her out of any restaurant
i love it yeah
yeah by the way they're the those dogs
are very protective smaller dude they
kicked somebody bubbles didn't draw
blood but i definitely got a little
something
on the middle finger
very protective they picked someone so
sophia wanted the dog yep wow but the
dog picked me
like she had her cousins her
girlfriend's over
you know look it's the the dog reveal
party i don't know whatever that is you
know
so everybody's there in the backyard and
uh and i had forgotten she's like joke i
meet the dog and i was like oh no we're
doing the dog thing that's right i'm
gonna have some little yappy
thing that you know it's gonna drive me
crazy and now but she picked me these
dogs pick one person and then that's it
and they don't want anybody else and
they defend you
and then they alert you when people are
coming towards you
and uh
[Laughter]
and they weigh under five pounds yeah
it's fantastic all right anyway all
right so joe manganiello is here
on the rich eisen show is our peacock
audience sees and we're back here on our
terrestrial radio uh audience rejoining
us here on nbc sports on peacock and nbc
sports audio siriusxm channel 85 sydney
crosby the rookie year is a new audible
original and it's created and written by
the stud sydney crosby himself and the
narrator is mr pittsburgh sports the
actor and producer joe manganiello here
on the rich eisen show along with
bubbles
the chihuahua
tucked into his right arm like uh a
football
oh yeah that's my heisman yeah i have to
go the other way and i made the mistake
of uh walking over and giving pebbles a
pet a little uh and she uh so do i have
to approach in any way or she will
always do that she's the temperament of
james harrison
she looks little
she's aggressive and she'll pick off
kurt warner at the best possible time
for you yes okay yeah i just said kurt
good to see you man great seeing you you
and you have thank you for bringing what
i want to say uh the sydney crosby uh
ricky year is written by neely loman oh
because it says created written by
sydney crosby
is a huge part of it obviously he was
interviewed his parents were interviewed
coaches
uh his old roommate right mario lemieux
right was also interviewed yes uh and uh
so it's kind of this look back this kind
of walk through his life during that
rookie season and what you don't
understand or what you get inside of is
yes you know just how
uh he was a child star
at age seven
there were people calling the house
asking about this kid no kidding yeah
come on and and all of the pressure of
growing up in canada um kind of the
weight of of growing up in these these
kind of like um you know mariner
communities these fishing small fishing
villages in eastern canada and uh being
the pride uh of his town and then coming
up and being drafted when he was 17
as the next great one turning 18 years
old shortly thereafter and then lemieux
stepping in and saying you're 18 years
old i don't want you to have to worry
about living alone figuring all that out
come live with me and my family and my
kids
in our house and so he lived with
lemieux his first what was that like he
sees
you know any stories well all the other
guys wanted to come over and visit
they're like you live at the owner's
house like i'm coming over right now
right um but yeah i know and then we get
into it and lemieux talks about it sid
talks about it um you know sid would go
down in the basement and play mini
sticks with the kids every night like
because he was a kid yeah you know and
um and you watch all the pressure put on
him and the target on his back during
that first season and uh it's really
extraordinary what he went through and
obviously looking back what it meant to
pittsburgh on the the verge of
bankruptcy uh being you know threatened
to be moved out of town lemieux steps in
liquidates all this money that they owe
them they own them 30 million dollars
and he took that in a in a controlling
interest in the team
and uh and then there was a lockout
season which means there's no draft
order and the penguins won
the bingo lottery and then got this kid
that that gave us nothing but sellouts
for the next 17 years and kept it kept
the team in town we've got some
photographs on the screen and you've
been telling the story what he he looks
like he was a child he was a kid yeah he
was a kid just seeing him here in these
photographs with a child in chap like
chapter four for example is his first
trip to philadelphia and everyone's
screaming crosby sucks yeah and they
they bash his teeth out
illegally
he comes back into the game and and
scores the winning goal so it's just you
couldn't
script
this any of this better i mean being uh
kept off of the olympic team by
wayne gretzky none under the man that he
was compared to and said he was the next
gretzky
gretzky keeps him from that initial
uh olympic team that everyone believed
he should have been on and then four
years later the olympics are in canada
he gets on the team and wins the
shootout against the us like it's just
the story is just incredible the way it
unfolds but you don't realize how much
pressure is on these kids you know i
think sometimes people uh they're
probably accustomed to like lebron's
story right when you're you're chosen at
this young age where where they actually
have the metrics and know this kid's
gonna be something i mean at seven years
old he was beating kids who were 12 and
13.
it was really incredible audible
original sydney crosby the rookie year
joe manganiello who narrates it right
here on the rich eisen show everyone
should it's it's fascinating that is uh
fascinating i'm sure you were like a kid
in a candy store it's really well done
too yeah and the way the way that they
set up the audio you know and there's
there's eight chapters so they all
unfold one after another and uh and you
know it's every everyone involved with
the entire story so you were mentioned
kid in a candy store um are you the kid
outside the candy store looking in and
seeing russell wilson as a denver bronco
right now i mean like what a as a
steeler fan
on a day like today where rogers stays
put and
the broncos mortgage the immediate
future right
you know what are you thinking now that
big ben's retired
no i i never thought we were going to
get those guys to go after those guys
because the cost is too much
but we're two years away we're not we're
not just at a quarterback and win the
super bowl team
i don't think we are i think we need i
mean when you have three all-pro
offensive linemen retiring the same year
right you got to retool and then of
course um you know twoit misses the
season alola gets hurt now you're two
defensive linemen down you know our
linebackers
didn't really inside linebackers didn't
pan out last year now we're two inside
linebackers away if joe hayden leaves
now we're a shutdown corner away those
are a lot of pieces at every level let
alone the fact that i'm not sure if we
have a clear number one wide receiver so
i mean those are those are big there's a
we're a couple of years away and so you
could plug in a rogers or a wilson but
who's going to block for them you know
and last year
was you know an interesting year coming
into the draft because i think they were
trying to surround ben with weapons in
case this was the last stand the last
push for him right for his window
and what happens was i think there were
some decisions made that
you know we could have wound up with
future hall of fame linemen who were
available when we were picking but we
were making choices i think based upon
winning now
to me i want to be competitive and of
course this is an organization that
likes to be competitive every year but i
just think right now we have to look at
it as there's two years
i think in two years we can retool if
we're smart and we do it right and we
have a great you know we have a lot of
cap room and uh and i think to give all
that away
for a quarterback without an offensive
line is is really difficult so that's a
very sensible
yeah
it's a very sensible take i think the
quarter the steelers next quarterback
will be some of the that they find in
the draft it's not going to be a so it's
like a sophomore in college junior in
college right now you think this isn't
the next big steal hopefully it's not
somebody in kindergarten because you
know i mean between
sean john roethlisberger for 21 years
um you know granted we we could have had
dan marino uh but we didn't yeah so by
the way get in line there's so many you
know
my team chose ken o'brien instead of him
everybody did yeah i know that's what
happened yeah i know that's exactly what
happened and so you know
i just don't know i mean it's possible
they could choose kenny pickett 20th
overall i mean speaking of the ghosts of
dan marino yesterday quarterback and i
kind of wondered about the hand size
thing if that was like the dan marino
marijuana thing you know what i mean
like like it's how do we get them to
drop in the draft so that the steelers
can get them at 20. i'm gonna say i'm
gonna say what just popped into my mind
i'll say it you can't hold a joint with
eight and a half inch hands
you can hold that problem you can hold a
roach man it's very difficult to do that
i did just say that
um but that is i i don't think that's a
big deal eight and a half inch hands i i
know but i know i mean if you didn't
know those measurements look at how good
he is on film if he didn't know that he
wouldn't it would honestly he put up the
photograph uh hoskins that we've been
using of him lately it's just we we've
used this photograph and then i didn't
think about it at all ever and then i
find out that his hands are eight and a
half inches
large and then all of a sudden i see the
photograph i'm like those hands dude
look a little small on the football does
he drop the ball a lot no i don't wear
this head he doesn't he doesn't at all
like i said i don't want to ruin
anything if this means he drops to 20
and is maybe available
right there
you know
coming out of the combine it's like you
know what like look see the hands right
there in the football in his hand it
just does it i don't know and i haven't
pulled out the tape measure but eight
and a half how i mean is that that's
pretty i think it's like my hand
i don't know i didn't get i didn't
measure my hand either tape measure for
joe but your hand is definitely not
eight and a half inches oh no your hand
is your hand is much lower yeah i would
think so yeah you know just got the ryan
leaf paw right there yeah
seriously when i normally shake hands
with an nfl quarterback their their hand
or like their index finger will reach up
to where my wristwatch is
that's the way it is i didn't i have not
i did not meet kenny pickett at the
combine i just think like i didn't think
about it at all watching him play in
pittsburgh then you hear it and it's
just like well i don't know there's
nobody who has hands like that if
michael vick was the last first round
draft choice who had hands that were
just eight and a half inches is that
right large yes he did okay
he did all right he did all right yes he
did so would you 20th overall if you
come away with him oh boy you just
mentioned
and kevin colbert is leaving his current
position as general manager um uh daniel
jeremiah who sat next to me for the
combine was talking about how he's
saying in many ways i think it was him
or somebody else told me uh that that
colbert would like to leave the team
with
[Music]
their next quarterback similar to ozzie
newsom who is still around i did see him
at the combine sure but i mean what do
you think about all that uh i mean if
he's available at 20 i mean it becomes
uh a naji hera situation i think where
you're hard-pressed to let it go or let
him pass by right um
because you could be looking at yeah you
could be looking at a starting
quarterback
with that said it's almost like
i mean
oh boy
i'd love to see some big stud offensive
lineman first round you know that what's
the the trevor guy the big one from
north
north with northern iowa yeah right he's
just like uh penning right yeah he like
throws i don't think he's like his first
round picks around like you said he'll
be gone yeah by then yeah i'm sure right
um but i mean there's there's such a
talented draft i mean the compound was
wild this year seeing 340 pound guys run
four sevens and things i know there is a
i don't know we haven't talked about it
yet there is a nebraska center
named cam jurgens
and um
he makes his own beef jerky and his
nickname is beef jergens
he makes his own beef jerky
yeah i mean he's a terrific center you
know i like jerky you know there you go
yeah but that's who you i don't think
you're i don't think of your talk that's
the northern iowa kid that you're
talking about yeah the big that monster
uh i think you're i don't think he's
gonna i don't know who the hell knows
because there's so many great defensive
players there's there's two ohio state
wide outs there's a couple of those
offensive linemen you can solve some
offensive line problems in free agency
and we have money for like the first
time in a long time i mean we really got
messed up because of that coveted cap
last year but i think we're back on
track this year we have to pay minka
fitzpatrick yes he definitely did for
sure right um but but past that maybe
you know maybe we could get some
journeyman offensive lineman in the
first round maybe there's a great
d-lineman okay who runs faster than our
wide receivers
that's available how's bubbles doing
how's how's bubbles getting through this
right now taking a nap right now she's
not really you see though so this is an
interesting game to play at home and
chihuahua yeah when i watch the steelers
because i'm used to screaming and
swearing at the tv and pacing and
yelling yes and trying not to put my
fist through the the tv screen well this
year
she doesn't go for that at all so it's
kind of like i have to
okay you know like that you gotta hold
it in even though you want to scream at
the top of your lungs but um
so
is she always in your arms or in your
lap like literally there are days that
go by where she doesn't touch the ground
[Laughter]
well because
like honestly joe you know we see
photographs on your instagram every now
and then and you know we it's just
you've this dog has been everywhere yeah
she she just got back from four months
in in ireland she lived with me oh
there's we're at the independent spirit
yeah with the spirit awards
there's her is that your bro yeah that's
my brother nick in the background
independent spirits okay there you go
she was really happy for simon rex she
really thought red rocket was a great
film she loved florida projects she's a
big fan of the filmmaker uh she was
happy about that one can you imagine can
you believe what your life has become
with this animal i mean
yeah like you know
a buddy of mine said to me um you were a
jacked werewolf like you know i mean you
were almost another super like come on
yeah well somebody one of my friends
said to me this is uh this is how mickey
rourke
happens
i said well no i i don't think that's
how it happened okay but there's
similarities but yeah but no this dog is
dead asleep right now she's passed out
she's wearing a little uh she's a little
her dad found out he was 20 irish with
23 and me okay so uh
yeah i found out well i found out last
year
when when you were in ireland before i
went to ireland so the show finding your
roots on pbs
i will be in an upcoming they're editing
my episode right now fantastic they
spent last year they spent 10 months
working on my genealogy and uncovered
like uh something a a secret that
everyone went to the grave with i got it
you're deep you're from a family of
browns fans
no
that would be tough you just broke into
a sweat right there yeah
that'd be tough i mean joe i hate to
break it to you we found out
your great great great grandfather was
was
diehard brown's fan it was paul brown
yes otto graham yes
okay sorry so you okay so
so yeah and and we uncovered the secret
so i i will in an upcoming episode of
finding your roots you'll find out
fantastic where that came from and how
and which side of my family what else
you got going on you always got about
fifteen what's going on um well there's
a pen there's um the upcoming medal
lords from uh d.b weiss we call him dan
and my dungeons and dragons come on but
he wrote this amazing movie for netflix
called metal lords which is about a
a group of kids uh not often represented
who are in a death metal band trying to
win the battle of the bands at their
high school and it's this heartwarming
like really fun great young high school
uh kid movie about kind of the tropes
and archetypes you don't often get in
those types of movies okay super fun
great music tom morello does all the
music there's some great great cameos
from huge rock stars in it and the kids
are so good like you will fall in love
with these kids so that's coming out
soon
um and um zack snyder's army of the dead
um anime
uh series will come out and then i've
got a couple other things that i'm
actually writing right now okay um that
uh hopefully i'll be able to announce
soon because they're like kind of
like
they're like dream projects of mine that
i've been working on for a year that i
haven't been able to talk okay yes you
know we're always here for you whenever
you got anything coming up and uh just
for anybody out there in our peacock
or siriusxm or terrestrial radio
audience um we're used to hearing it but
yes joe manganiello is in a dungeons and
dragons group
and one of the members is one of the
creators of the game of thrones
television theory uh series um
dby stan wise right and and dave benioff
played he's in it too yeah so actually
uh the the people who brought game of
thrones to life on hbo are dungeons and
dragons members well they they grew up
playing it i mean which makes sense
which is what the show became yeah um
and um and yeah so they play characters
in my show
every week or you know the the the
adventure they they don't have to they
don't have to write they just have to
show up and they get to play their
characters yeah that's really fun right
which is like a with the the 25 sided
die and stuff like that twenty-sided
yeah twenty-sided damage yeah gave five
too many sides and and uh does your your
wife still refer to you guys as the
nerds does she refer to you guys as the
nerd still uh i prefer intellectual
does bubbles make it into the dungeons
and dragons room bubble sits on my lap
while i run the games and just takes a
nap she just goes you're the grand
master is that what it is dungeon master
dungeon master okay
yeah
yeah
i'm not making fun of you you seem like
i'm making fun of you i'm not doing it i
mean there's a little bit you you were
close enough to 20. i think you knew it
was the 20 side of that but you went 25
to try to hide your tracks if i only had
my cloak of invisibility on right now
there it is okay there you go just get
in the game just get in the game i know
yeah i get i get destroyed in two
seconds like i'd be dead i'd be dead
before i hit the floor i'll walk you
through it it's you i mean and you
couldn't make it you could make the
greatest character ever rich like what
what i don't know whatever you want to
do what do you think you cast spells do
you fight do you do a little bit of both
i never really thought of it that's good
i'm a spell caster that's a good i do
that every day that's a good one yeah
the rich eyes and show uh audience is
spellbound every day you could like
throw throw flames like that
yeah fireballs yeah
yeah
lightning bolts fireballs why wouldn't
anybody create the most powerful
character of all time because you start
off as like a little tadpole and then
you have to grow
you have to grow yeah but that's the fun
of it you're on an ongoing series
you're in game of thrones you succumb to
our game of thrones parties every week
this is your chance to be on the show
who do you want to be the mountain you
want to be jon snow who do you want to
be
daenerys whatever you want showing up
and having you know and drinking and
watching tv if george martin came to
play would you would you come on yeah
oh i talked jets with him
he's a diehard
yes i talked jets with him so you're
saying george's whales wait a minute
they were supposed to covet hit so we
had to stop playing live because kovitt
hit this zoo
but george was going to come over yeah
then we started doing it by zoom
yeah does the does the
how do you so you roll the die on zoom
and is there just like so there's a
program where i put up the map and each
character can only see what you can see
so if you have like night vision you can
see i program how far you can see if you
have a torch it flickers and you can see
how far and you can only see what you
can see so sometimes people in the zoom
are like oh no and you're like because
you can't see it what happened what
happened get up here you know and then
you have to get into a fight okay so i
have the map up here and then we have
zoom over there so we can you know see
each other ballpark it for me what's my
time commitment if i start this process
ballpark what is it well i mean
i mean this is like this is like hey man
i you know um i mean what's my time if
you were like hey i wanna i wanna
deadlift 600 by next year are you like
what's my what's my time commitment uh
before i deadlift 600 joe and i'm like
well i don't know rich
let's get in there
and see where you're at
and uh
and then we'll go from there is it
offensive that i'm asking for what the
time commitment is i should just want to
hang out right like that's the way
that's what it is it's like a lot of us
were poker players who when we were kids
yes
played this game right you know and so
when we were kids i mean geez i mean
when you're a kid it was like you'd play
12 hours your mom would make english
muffin pizzas you go to sleep you wake
up and start again
you know that was how it was so now it's
like we get a food truck i have the food
truck come to the driveway we all eat
and then and then we go and honestly i
would you know it's like guys it's
midnight who has to be up tomorrow
anybody no i do but let's go you know
and then okay you know now it's one
what's 1 30 in the morning guys
2 2 30. they want to you want to keep
going
so it's it's a thing like it could be it
could be three hours hanging out
these guys they like to go seven seven
seven yeah yeah i already established
last hour as you're making your way down
here i only wait ten minutes for friends
that's it i don't think rich is a good
fit for this joke
come on this is uh i mean you don't know
who's in my group big show you ever
you're hanging with the big show you
ever have him on the show big show the
big show from wrestling paul white oh
sure yeah
you've seen
he loves d he used to fly in from
florida every weekend to play i'll come
in so the big show you've got uh a
crossfit champion who you've met my my
former trainer ron the crossfit champion
um
play with you joe what's up vince vaughn
does he play with vince vaughn yeah
you've got james gunn used to play taran
kill him from saturday night live very
funny guy
yeah he's a happy guy these days yeah he
is yeah all right yeah well we have i
i'll i'll text you okay
linebacker cassius marsh he's going to
make a character oh wow
the last time i saw post malone he
wanted to play so maybe i don't know we
get posting in there without hearing me
post yeah he's supposed to do it he
plays magic cards i play magic with
posts
damn all right i'm in cat you know what
cash is smarter
he created a character that taunts the
other side by just looking at them
right but it's just staring just staring
it's just looking like
you you imply what you want to imply
tony currency's character hip jack i
know
he's the dungeon master unfortunately
everybody check out the audible original
sydney crosby the rookie year narrated
by joe manganiello take care joe thanks
for bringing bubbles man
she's
sleepy fantastic an entire interview and
appearance with bubbles and uh
like like the like the duke four points
of pressure uh what are we teasing going
to break so we are teasing aaron rodgers
has spoken
you want to take a phone call don't do
that sports talk right here let's do it
you wanna open his microphone mike the
man stayed around with his dog
my gosh uh duggan north carolina has
been waiting an hour almost two hours
what's up doug
you're on with your doug you're on the
rich eisen show with joe manganiello and
bubbles the chihuahua you on
yes hey rich i'm here i just wanted to
let you know that
i may be the only one in america who
will say this
aaron rodgers is the most overrated
athlete of all time wow he beats up on
one division
three teams twice a year
and then goes about 500 the rest of the
season gets into the playoffs and people
wonder why he can't win well the reason
is he's he's just a
slightly above average quarterback
and i disagree with you i think that
broncos said do we want uh
wilson and rogers who thought that
rogers rejected the broncos i think the
broncos
chose wilson over rogers
well um i'll push back on that one doug
um you know and and say
he's generationally talented
and um outside of you know those six
games that he plays there was some time
where chicago uh actually performed
pretty well um he's won 13 games last
three years from age 35 on with a new
coach so i'll just push back on you on
that
well tell me a uh hall of fame playoff
quarterback he uh tell me a hall of fame
quarterback that he beat in the playoffs
um
couldn't beat
uh kaepernick he couldn't beat uh kurt
warner arguably i think he beat uh eli
once but when he faces a good
quarterback in the playoffs
hold on a second joe you want to handle
that one i mean i don't want to say this
because i was at that game and it was
like the worst night of my life but he
he he won super bowl 45 against ben
roethlisberger he's going to the hall i
mean and ben's first again ben's gonna
be first round
i appreciate the call doug thanks for
calling in i appreciate you hanging on
for as long as you did i hated that game
god and the blizzard everything about
that yeah that that that was a wild
wild week
yes no cab drivers were drifting into
parking lots
i knew we were in trouble when i saw the
metroplex as we were dropped we we went
in the snow in a blizzard to the media
day because it wasn't media night yet on
a tuesday and i saw this huge next to
the stadium huge pile of sand and i'm
like what's that for
and the driver you know who's local said
that's what we put on the roads when it
gets icy and i'm like
no you put sand on the roof it's salt
and you need trucks there's no ice truck
that's it yeah i know we were we were
all the all of us from the east coast
were like
sand yeah they said iran that ain't
working raising arizona that's right
you ate i ate sand that's right you ate
sand
you're gonna buy a couch from unpainted
huffles
blow up in all kind of funny shapes not
unless you think rounds funny
back here on the rich eisen show
terrestrial radio network um joe
manganiello is still here okay so what
do we got aaron rodgers has aaron
rodgers tweeted everybody let's check it
out uh hey everyone just want to clear
some things up yes i will be playing
with the packers next year however
reports about me signing a contract are
inaccurate as are the supposed terms of
the contract i signed i'm very excited
to be back
year 18.
we did a handshake
i don't know we didn't sign we just
shook hands i don't know what that means
well i'm trying to see if
people were reporting that he actually
signed i don't i don't know
well ian's language was agreed to terms
yeah
i don't know who's saying that they
signed so
uh nobody has said signed but i don't
know
i don't know okay look
there's something going on with devonte
adams right
yep like he's got a
he's got to get that guy signed long
term he
meaning
and aaron rodgers he
needs him signed long term too like he's
got to bring his own like he's not going
to
sign a monster deal and what and devonte
doesn't get his long-term deal like that
first-hand topic this morning rich does
aaron rodgers need devonte adams to be a
top five quarterback
he needs to of course any quarterback
need
somebody to throw to who is incredible
to make you a top five quarterback
he's got the do you know how many top
how about this
how about this that's why i was how
about this
did did um matthew stafford look like a
top five quarterback this year
uh yeah it's okay at times right right
right right right right through a lot
did he look like a top five quarterback
since uh calvin johnson was gone
uh not really you need to
you know what i'm saying like you need
to have someone to throw to sure but
also when you say things like people
come to green bay because they want to
play with me therefore i want to be
consulted i want to be brought into the
fold yes okay well
get him signed
do you know what i mean like there's a
bit of that when you come out and say
that
then okay well where's all the guys
coming where's all where's the tampa bay
team that signs for a year around you to
push you over the top and get you that
super bowl in green bay let's go
right
although i i'll say this though i mean
um
you know devonte adams
there's something going on like they got
devante adams didn't want to come back
to green bay if aaron's gone right right
you would think i mean
and aaron and aaron is like you know
part of the reason why i want to stay
here obviously the money's pretty darn
good devonte is coming back right i mean
why would he want to stay and not have
the greatest receiver in the game with
whom he has a sixth sense there yeah so
this all has to be figured out
somebody's got to go first though right
they can't just say the deals are all
this and in three two one everybody sign
it once like go like there has to be
some somebody has to go first but i
think there's also something to be said
for chemistry in the nfl you know
there's 11 players on each side if two
players have chemistry like a
quarterback and a wide receiver you see
it happen all the time where it's like
it's like the dog with the bone in their
mouth that sees the reflection
of the dog with the bone and thinks i
want two bones and they wind up with
zero you see that happens so many times
where these players go and move
somewhere thinking they're look at obj
look at what it took for him to get back
on track with a quarterback that he had
chemistry with
you know you you kind of you ruined the
middle of your career you know if you
don't look at ab i mean these are you
know you kind of never get back on on
your footing and if you're wide receiver
that has a great quarterback chemistry
stay
what about the dog that falls asleep in
his father's forearm what about that dog
you uh you signed that one with a
long-term deal
bubbles is locked right fifth year
option
yeah well she's in she's still in a
rookie contract with me okay
no she
look at this dog she was a trade twitter
reports that the tower rocket might also
be on the move
geez tyler lockett
go to your seahawk fan of your life and
give that person a hug today
joe manganiello and bubbles hanging out
words i never thought i'd say before she
heard her name she just perked up
bubbles can you hear me bubbles ah she's
back to sleep now i'll see you
uh final poll results christopher uh
actually let's let joe vote on them and
give us the final results okay go for it
what are we gonna do so we have afc west
who you got broncos chiefs chargers
raiders broncos chiefs chargers
raiders
careful stone street listens
i'm going broncos now my hot take as of
today i think they're ready to go this
is not going to get 22 percent that's
the chiefs division 54 percent what
happened to my homes last year what
happened to him in that game until i
find that out
i'm going broncos next five years one of
these teams will win a super bowl who
you got cowboys packers
oh that's it oh uh next five years
one of them will win we're just
anointing one which fine packers if it's
75
uh now who comes out of the nfc with
rogers sticking around packers rams
49ers cowboys
49ers with tom brady
geez everybody
man what's your okay so tom brady heat
checks tv 12 heat check we came up with
this like many great ideas on this show
off the top of our head yesterday on the
air tb12 heat check
uh on a scale of zero to twelve
uh zero he's running lines doing jello
shots with rita moreno he's got no
chances he's not no thought of coming
back 12 he's coming back where are you
on the tb12 heat check right now um i
think
what do you got
i'm going to go 10 he's coming back 10
10 and 12. florio is 11.997
i think he's coming back i mean there's
there's gas in the tank you know i don't
think he'd go out right now i think he
could go somewhere else thanks for
coming on hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here